[Applause]
[Music]
dawn and the Train are both breaking
when ethic and hedge arrive in the woods
the adventurers have recovered the first
artifact the node of power and have come
to the 198 forest in search of the
second here they're welcomed by the
director of the colony Octavia
she established this treehouse sanctuary
after the robots freed everyone from
having to work it was meant to be a
haven where people could follow their
passions take up crafts and find
fulfilment which they did at first some
years ago everyone forgot the point they
abandoned arts and crafts and instead
just painted and exhibited pictures of
themselves over and over and over the
location of the second artifact is no
secret it's in a tower guarded by a
garrison of bots a bottomless ravine and
who knows what other traps as soon as
the tower went up with the node inside
human communication across the land went
dark Octavia has been after it for years
but try as she might the defenses worker
in order to even get to the tower the
team will need a distraction Octavia has
an idea stir up the people through some
well intentioned vandalism the residents
paintings are all squares that come in
different sizes all an odd number of
pixels across helper BOTS pick up the
finished portraits and hang them in
public places for everyone to admire
there's a slim margin of time when hedge
can access the paintings if he were to
deface each one with an X the people
would blame the helper box creating just
the distraction the team needs if only
it were so easy hedge can't just paint
an X his painting processor requires
very specific instructions treating the
paintings as square grids he can fill in
one pixel or little square at a time he
can move forwards and make 90-degree
turns over the canvas
can't move diagonally how does ethic
program hedge to paint an x over each
portrait here's a hint try drawing a
square grid like this and simulating
hedges path over it what patterns can
you find to guide him the challenge here
is to craft a set of instructions that
will work for any square grid
fortunately one of the strengths of
programming is the flexibility to solve
not just one problem but a whole class
of them all at once it often helps to
start with one case and work towards the
general let's say we had this square
hedge can measure the length of its
sides and store that number as a
variable now what we need is a plan for
how hedge will paint an x pixel by pixel
there's more than one right answer for
how to do this let's look at two first
what if hedge went row by row like a
typewriter if it's a nine pixel by nine
pixel painting in the first row he'd
paint skip seven and then paint again in
the second row he'd skip the first paint
skip five and paint and so on the
pattern here is that for each row the
pixels skipped at the beginning go up by
one and the pixels skipped in the middle
go down by two things get more
complicated when hedge reaches the
center here there's a row with just one
pixel painted then the whole thing
reverses the number of pixels skipped
goes down by one each time on the left
and up by two each time in the middle
instructing hedge to do this with a
series of loops will work and is a
perfectly fine solution the main
drawback is that this requires quite a
bit of logic knowing what to do in the
middle when to reverse the process and
exactly how to reverse it
so how might we approach this so that
the logic remains consistent from start
to finish the key insight is to look at
a grid as a series of concentric squares
each square follows the same pattern
painted pixels in the corners and
unaltered pixels in between so if we can
figure out a way to paint one nested
square transition to the next and repeat
we can paint them all painting the
outermost one is easy start in the
corner and paint that pixel if we call
the length of the painting and fly
forward n minus 1 spaces paint another
pixel and turn right now do the whole
thing again and again now move forward
one less space turn right
fly forward once and hedge will be in
the next concentric square and ready to
repeat the whole process each square is
n minus 2 pixels smaller than the last
in length and width and we can follow
this spiral pattern all the way to the
center with a loop and a variable that
tracks how far head should fly is one of
these methods better than the other it
really depends on what you value the
strength of the spiral is the simplicity
of finding a pattern and reusing the
same logic from start to finish the
advantage of the typewriter approach is
that it's a more generalized solution
meaning it can be adapted much more
simply to fill in any pattern for ethics
sake either will do just fine
so here's what happens hedge rapidly D
faces all of the portraits and within
moments cries of anguish break out all
over
Forrest the garrison guarding the tower
abandoned their posts to calm the
agitated people and ethic hedge and
Octavia slipped through and nearly
slipped into the depths of the gorge
standing between them and the tower
continue the adventure in Episode six of
think like a coder or we start the
journey with episode 1 and don't forget
to subscribe
[Music]